how long does it take to learn to ride a
bicycle no one knows you know it's
impossible to guess but it's a process
and if you follow the process and you
follow the regime and you have a little
discipline a hundred percent you'll get
into shape but no one knows when
and business is the same right which is
if you follow the process there's a few
things that that are pretty stable
and you go through the motions sometimes
it's quicker and sometimes it's lower
but don't worry if it's not meeting
arbitrary goals the trends the trend
data is much more important than the
absolute targets
if you're trending in the right
direction be happy regardless whether
you hit the goal or not it's a process
and I think business we have to remember
yeah for as much talent and you know uh
uh you know beauty that there is and
creativity that there is in in building
a business some of it's some of it's
discipline and rigor